elle est beaucoup plus courte qu'une raquette de
tennis et les trous sont pour alléger la raquette.
On sent vraiment qu'elle est plus légère. Une
raquette facile à manier pour un sport encore peu
connu : le paddle, qui peut être prononcé "padel"
en référence à ses origines latines. Un sport
moins violent que le squash et plus facile que le
tennis où il faut allier rapidité et attention.
Pour la pratique c'est en double sur un terrain
légèrement plus petit qu'un court de tennis et
ce n'est pas la seule différence. En tennis on
essaie de ne jamais laisser passer la balle le but
c'est la renvoyer. Là, très très régulièrement,
des balles qui viennent très fort on va essayer
de justement de la laisser rebondir, de laisser
rebondir sur le mur du fond et éventuellement de
la reprendre, même en s'étant rapproché du filet
par rapport à au point d'origine et donc du coup
on peut contre-attaquer. Donc en fait quand on
attaque on sait jamais si ça va être vraiment
une attaque, si une attaque va pas se retourner
contre nous, et donc c'est pour ça que c'est pas
un jeu où on doit taper très fort sinon si on tape
fort et mal, on se prend la balle encore plus dur
dans les dents ensuite. Le padel serait né il y
a une trentaine d'années sur le terrain de tennis
privé d'un couple mexicain. La femme ayant du mal
à frapper la balle son mari l'aurait autorisée à
la laisser rebondir sur le mur de la maison avant
de la renvoyer de l'autre côté du filet. Que l'on
y croit ou pas le padel a bien évolué depuis :
avant les mur étaient en briques et les balles
partaient très très rapidement, et là maintenant
avec les vitres, on a descendu aussi les niveaux
les hauteurs sur les côtés et on a ouvert les
portes, ce qui permet aux joueurs haut niveau
de sorties du terrain pour ramener les balles.
Le padel présente un avantage de taille : une
demi heure suffit pour trouver ses marques. Si ce
sport prend de plus en plus d'ampleur en France,
encore peu de structures sont dédiées à ces
pratiques et le nombre de joueurs n'est pas
encore référencé. En comparaison depuis son
arrivée à la fin des années 80 en Espagne,
le sport de raquette fait un tabac :le pays compte
trois millions de joueurs à l'heure actuelle